let's turn our attention to the united
states now where interest rates have
risen by 0.75
that's the biggest hike since 1994. well
our u.s correspondent martha kellner
joins us now so why the need for this
big rate move martha
yeah this is a three-quarters of a
percent rise in interest rates it's the
biggest single hike as you mentioned
there anna for 28 years the federal
reserve which is the u.s central bank
the equivalent of the bank of england is
sending a message to lenders but also to
the american people that they recognize
that the cost of living is going up and
they're committed to doing something
about it to that end the federal the
chair of the federal reserve jerome
powell has been giving an address in the
past half an hour he was blaming the war
in ukraine as well as other events for
rising inflation and he said they have
to be cruel to be kind in a way they
have to hurt the economy in order to
help the american people and i think we
can hear a little bit of what he said
the surge in prices of crude oil and
other commodities that resulted from
russia's invasion of ukraine
is boosting prices for gasoline and food
and is creating additional upward
pressure on inflation
and covet ready covert related lockdowns
in china are likely to exacerbate supply
chain disruptions my colleagues and i
are acutely aware that high inflation
imposes significant hardship especially
on those least able to meet the higher
costs of essentials like food housing
and transportation
clearly today's 75 basis point increase
is an unusually large one and i do not
expect moves of this size to be common
that's jerome powell there the chair of
the federal reserve the federal reserve
have been gently nudging up interest
rates over the past few months in order
to try and bring down
inflation so far unsuccessfully so this
0.75
rise is a rather more blunt instrument
to tackle rising inflation which is a
big problem in the american economy at
the moment the problem in a nutshell is
one that's familiar to people in the uk
during the pandemic people were saving
money they then emerged from the
pandemic with spare money if you like
more disposable income that meant there
was more of more demand for goods and in
turn a rising cost of goods and that's
not being brought under control by these
gentle price risers consumer price these
gentle
interest rate rises if you like
instead consumer prices rose by 8
in may that means we've seen a rising
cost of food gas
and housing president biden recognizes
that this is not only a problem for the
american people but it also reflects on
his presidency presidential fortunes are
often tied to the strength or weakness
of an economy so he's trusting the
federal reserve to tackle inflation in a
way that his predecessor the former
president donald trump didn't do so
president biden trusting them to tackle
inflation and bring it back under
control even if it will be painful for
the american people in the short term
martha thank you